This video was made possible by CuriosityStream.
When you sign up at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover,
you’ll also get access to Nebula—the streaming
video platform that Wendover is a part of.
There’s a battle going on in the Pacific.
The People’s Republic of China and the Republic
of China, more commonly known as Taiwan, have
fought their territorial dispute for generations,
but now, nearly each and every one of the
tiny nations dotting the Pacific Ocean has
emerged as a battlefield for this conflict.
The weapons of this war are not guns and bullets,
but rather concrete and banknotes.
This is a diplomatic mission aiming to shore
up the support of some of the world’s smallest
countries.
There are fourteen nations in question here:
Palau, Papua New Guinea, the Federated States
of Micronesia, the Solomon Islands, Nauru,
Vanuatu, the Marshall Islands, Fiji, Tuvalu,
Tonga, Kiribati, Samoa, Niue, and the Cook
Islands.
With the exception of Papua New Guinea, each
of these have populations below one million
and each also tends to have fairly low GDP
per capita’s—generally between one and
five thousand dollars.
This means that they’re each granted fairly
significant amounts of foreign aid.
In the previous decade, Niue, for example,
received $134 million in aid, or about $83,000
for each member of its population.
Region-wide that average is only in the low-thousands,
but the point is that the Pacific gets a lot
of aid.
Now, most of this does not come from Taiwan
or China.
Australia is by far the largest donor.
It is important for Australia to be in these
countries’ good graces for strategic reasons.
For example, 6% of Australia’s GDP is made
up solely of exports that take one of these
three maritime routes—each of which passes
by some of these Pacific countries.
These trade routes could be disrupted if there
were instability in the Pacific.
Political stability also keeps foreign powers
from attempting a power-grab in any of these
nations, and any such power-grab would likely
be too close for comfort for Australia.
So, the primary aid motivation for Australia
and its close allies, like New Zealand and
the US, is stability.
That is not the primary motivation for China
and Taiwan.
These two powers are openly engaging in what's
known as "checkbook diplomacy.”
They're buying diplomatic partners through
financial aid, but why?
China is a massive nation of more than a billion
people.
What benefit does it receive from having tiny
nations like Samoa, Tonga, or Fiji on its
side?
Well, they might gain some limited benefit,
but the main reason China works to build these
diplomatic partnerships is so Taiwan can not.
That’s because, to Taiwan, even a tiny,
eleven-thousand person nation like Tuvalu
is hugely valuable as Tuvalu has something
Taiwan doesn’t.
Tuvalu is a member of the United Nations.
Taiwan is rarely recognized as an independent
country in international settings.
This is despite the fact that, in almost every
way, it acts and operates as an independent
country would.
There are plenty of countries, like the US,
for example, that have strong relations with
Taiwan and treat it as if it were a country.
The US has a de-facto embassy in Taiwan, recognizes
Taiwanese passports, sells military supplies
to Taiwan, and has an enormously strong trade
relationship with Taiwan, yet it does not
recognize Taiwan as a country.
That’s because, in international relations,
there is an implicit rule: you either recognize
the Republic of China or the People’s Republic
of China.
Now, given the choice between working with
the world’s most populous country or a moderately-sized
island of 24 million, nearly every nation
picks China.
Even though Taiwan and the US are functionally
allies while China and the US are frenemies,
at best, it’s just not worthwhile for the
US to recognize Taiwan as a country.
This is the case for almost every country—that
is, of course, unless Taiwan makes it worthwhile.
Across the Pacific, Taiwan has been funding
projects to keep small nations on its side.
In Palau, they spent $1.3 million to help
the country recover from Typhoon Haiyan.
In Papua New Guinea, they spent $4.5 million
to improve domestic agriculture in order to
increase food security.
In the Solomon Islands, they spent $2.5 million
to train local staff and conduct a survey
of the islands’ local plant species.
In Nauru, they spent $600 thousand donating
more-efficient compact fluorescent lightbulbs
to local households.
In the Marshall Islands, they spent $1 million
building a seawall around Majuro Atoll to
protect it from rising sea-levels.
In Fiji, they spent $300 thousand improving
mental health service access around the country.
In Tuvalu, they spent $200 thousand repairing
and improving water storage equipment around
the country after a cyclone.
In Kiribati, they spent $19 million to repair
and upgrade the country’s main airport.
Each of these projects, and the hundreds more
funded by Taiwan around the pacific, improves
its relations with these countries, and therefore
brings it more and more diplomatic clout.
Taiwan can’t afford to buy the support of
large nations, but in some settings the size
of the nation doesn’t matter.
In the United Nations General Assembly, for
example, it’s one country, one vote.
It doesn’t matter if it’s Tuvalu or China,
when voting, every member nation has the exact
same power.
There are other systems in the UN where power
is more balanced based on population, but
overall, the world’s smallest nations have
a disproportionate amount of power.
More recognition, even by the smallest countries,
strengthens Taiwan’s case for a position
in intergovernmental organizations like the
UN.
That’s why Taiwan targets small nations
for support.
$5 million spent on Tuvalu goes a lot further
than $5 million spent on Mexico, for example,
but in the General Assembly, Tuvalu can help
Taiwan just as much as Mexico can.
This diplomatic clout that Taiwan has amassed,
though, gets in the way of China’s ambition
of eventually unifying the two.
It is for that reason that the People’s
Republic has gone on the offensive.
China has been courting Taiwan’s diplomatic
partners in the Pacific with promises of larger
aid packages.
The most recent two defectors were Kiribati
and the Solomon Islands.
Early in the 2010’s China provided no foreign
aid to either of these countries, but then,
as soon as they each revoked their recognition
of Taiwan, promises of planes, ferries, medical
supplies, and more started pouring in from
China.
In addition to these two countries, Taiwan
has lost diplomatic support from the Dominican
Republic, Burkina Faso, El Salvador, Panama,
and São Tomé and Príncipe since 2016.
That leaves them with just fifteen total diplomatic
partners, and only four in the Pacific region.
To maintain the limited support that it has,
Taiwan has had to get tactical.
China’s style with aid is to build big,
flashy, expensive infrastructure projects.
In Fiji, they spent $50 million building a
paved road that halved the time it took for
local farmers to get to markets, but local
engineers reportedly said that a far lower-quality
and cheaper road could have achieved the same
result.
In Vanuatu, they spent $80 million upgrading
a port to allow for larger cruise ships to
dock, but in all of 2019, for example, just
five visited.
In Papua New Guinea, they spent $1 million
building a malaria hospital in the capital
of Port Moresby, despite that being the region
of the country with the least malaria, and
despite the capital having no road link to
the regions with the worst malaria outbreaks.
Each of these projects and more clearly have
positive effects, but undoubtably they are
not the most efficient uses of $1 or $50 or
$80 million in the mission of improving relations
between China and these Pacific nations.
China does big, flashy, and sometimes ineffective
aid.
Taiwan does small, personable, and generally
more effective aid.
That’s why they have been able to maintain
the relationships they have for so long, despite
a much lower budget.
China works to impress the governments, Taiwan
works to impress the people.
Taiwan’s average aid project size in the
Pacific is $500,000.
China’s is $6 million.
Taiwan does things like contribute $1,600
for Palau’s baseball team to attend a tournament
in Guam, or spend $200,000 buying a boat for
an outer atoll in the Marshall Islands, or
construct $300,000 of solar street lights
in Nauru.
The $80 million port in Vanuatu might help
people more than the $1,600 for the baseball
team in Palau, but one can be sure that every
member of that team and their families and
friends heard about and remember how Taiwan
helped them.
That’s less likely with the large, somewhat
ineffective port.
Taiwan knows that the choice of which side
to support is a political issue in the Pacific
because there is that choice.
Pretty much any politician in these countries
will run their campaign with the Taiwan issue
as part of their platform and so Taiwan is
trying to gain the support of everyday people.
They want to win support from the ground-up,
rather than from the top-down.
This might create a better value for their
money, but at the end of the day, China just
has so much more money.
If China wants to win the political support
of a small nation, they can just spend and
spend and spend.
At this point, Taiwan’s few, tiny diplomatic
partners are no longer a threat to China’s
goal of reunification.
China will likely keep courting these nations,
not because they need to, but because it’ll
further weaken Taiwan.
Eventually, though, if there comes a day when
the Taiwan issue is resolved, either through
reunification or recognized independence,
the Pacific islands will be victims because,
when it's no longer useful, the pawn is the
first to be sacrificed.
If you want to learn more about one of the
four Pacific-island nations that are still
on Taiwan’s side, the Marshall Islands,
you can watch the Nebula-exclusive documentary
we filmed on location in the Marshall Islands.
You heard earlier that Taiwan funded a seawall
for the capital, Majuro, but The Final Years
of Majuro explains why that was necessary,
and what it means for the nation.
It explains what life is like in a nation
with an expiration date.
The best way to get access to that is to sign
up for CuriosityStream’s Nebula bundle deal.
Curiosity Stream is, of course, home to thousands
of documentaries that any Wendover viewer
will enjoy, and Nebula is home to all of Wendover’s
normal videos early and ad-free, plus special,
exclusive projects like this documentary.
What’s more, it’s not only Wendover on
there, but Half as Interesting, Real Engineering,
Braincraft, TierZoo, Real Life Lore, and more
and more of your favorite educational creators.
So, once again, sign up for any subscription
at CuriosityStream.com/Wendover for as little
as $20 a year and get access to Nebula for
free.